bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i am super
excited i've got people here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
hey thanks for having me super
appreciate it
absolutely all right we've been trying
to do this for a while we finally got it
scheduled we're finally both here i
finally didn't cancel
yeah okay it's like you kind
listen we've been talking for a long
long time uh
and i i really really wanted to do it
but we had one incident come up where i
had to reschedule it
but we're here now um all right let's
start with your background everyone
knows you as this amazing digital artist
probably the number one digital artist
in the world today
uh and they're like who the hell is the
people uh where did you grow up
what is your background how did you get
into digital art sure
so this is long story short i'm from
wisconsin
um and i you know a small town in
wisconsin
went to school for computer science
about halfway through the degree
realized i don't want to be a programmer
kind of was like okay let me just get
through this stuff and like i
during that time in college i was
spending all my time making weird little
like short films and art stuff and this
is back in you know 1999 to 2003 so i'm
39
this was a while ago um and so after i
got done with college
i got a job doing like web design again
this is back in wisconsin
um for like a smaller company in in
wisconsin there and really sort of
putting all my
sort of real kind of like energy and
passion into like
you know the personal work outside of
that job um
and so three or four years after i
started that job
i started the everydays and from there i
saw a big sort of
you know kind of uh boost in in sort of
just
output of work that i was doing um and
uh
just the amount that i was learning you
know very very rapidly
um and so after starting every days i
started
also releasing um these creative commons
sort of like vj clips which were
basically custom little vj
clips that that abstract sort of like
loops that anybody could use for
for anything um and so from there i
started getting a bunch of
uh like concert visual like uh music
artists sort of looking for custom
concert visuals and so that was like a
huge part of the sort of like freelance
work that i did over the last you know
10 years or so
um and you know since then it's kind of
really just been sort of a slow steady
progression and people sort of like
noticing my work and sort of um you know
bigger and better sort of clients coming
to me and looking for work
um and then obviously fast forward to
you know four months ago
with the nf came to the the sort of nft
and crypto arts base and that's when it
really just
what the [ __ ] is going on so
yeah it's been really pretty slow and
steady up until the past
uh uh three four months here then it's
been a [ __ ] rocket ride
it's been a rocket route all right so
let's talk about uh the
everydays um when did you start
this way you've been 5 000 or more of
them what was the idea behind doing the
everydays and how did you get started
sure so those started in um may 1st 2007
was the the first every day and i saw an
illustrator out of the uk named tom judd
who did a
sketch a day and i thought that was a
really cool idea and
and i wanted to get better at drawing
and so the first every days are actually
drawing i i wanted to get better drawing
so it's like okay i'm going to do a
drawing every day
and after a year of that i realized i
learned a lot
about drawing um i was still very very
bad as i still
am today very bad that's not like i am
actually really bad
um and so but and so i thought maybe i
could take that
and use it to teach myself a 3d program
which i didn't know any 3d
program um and so i started doing a
render every day that's what it's called
when you sort of
make a program in a 3d program or make a
picture in a 3d program
so i started doing a render a day using
cinema 4d
um and then i kind of just you know
again kept doing that for the
next 12 years and so the everydays are
again a picture
start to finish every single day i'm not
like
banking these up um it's about
two hours per per day roughly you know
it sort of varies
wildly depending on what's going on that
day um
but yeah that's kind of you know sort of
always been the case and it's got to be
posted somewhere
online before midnight and that's sort
of the kind of boundaries of the
where do you come up with the ideas
you've got some absolutely
epic things you've created you've got
some gruesome things
some inappropriate things there's some
nasty things
some nasty nasty [ __ ] um where do you
come
with the ideas so it's one of these
things where
um i come up with the ideas a lot of
looking at other people's stuff like i'm
very much
inspired by other people's work and sort
of looking around
and and um seeing different things and
it might be
you know a different shape it might be
like oh i never thought of making you
know a creature like that or
you know having this sort of scale or
this sort of perspective so it's really
pulling from a bunch of different people
sort of um a bunch of different digital
artists
work that that's a big piece of it that
is definitely a huge inspiration
and then i would say the other thing is
just like current events like i i'm
very much into um you know current
events and sort of what's going on and
inspired by
politics and sort of internet culture
and sort of what's going on in the
internet
and um you know financial happenings
and and you know the tech companies and
their sort of relationship with people
so
there's a bunch of different sort of
things you know themes that that
kind of come into play each day but i
sort of look at it as being almost like
a digital cartoon
or a political cartoonist sometimes but
instead of you know just doing a sketch
i i'm using like the most advanced 3d
tools to to make something
that um you know would
in the past take you know a bunch of
time now because the tools are so
powerful i'm able to do it you know just
in a few hours
yeah and so when you think about this um
why go from doing like this amazing
uh digital art that obviously you're
very very skilled at
to then the nfts was it something that
you saw with the technology
uh with the market like what caused you
to
want to try the nfts rather than just
continue to post the digital art on
instagram and other places
well i think with the nfts i mean one it
was sort of like okay well people are
making a lot of money on this if i may
be totally honest like that
is definitely uh it was and they're
selling something that i never really
even thought you could sell
and so it's kind of like oh this
actually makes total sense to be able to
collect my very digital artwork
in a digital way because before i i
would sell prints and stuff like that
and it's sort of like that's one thing
you can kind of you know take my work
and print it out but
like my work is digital and so it's
meant to sort of be viewed on a screen
um and so being able to sell it and
collect it in a digital way
you know is something that to me is very
exciting and something i i didn't really
see sort of coming that wasn't really
like oh in the future there will be a
way to sort of like
you know collect this and have it it'd
be feel very natively digital that that
definitely was not on my radar as i
don't think
it was pretty much anybody's um so
that to me is is very exciting and then
just
like nfts in general really sort of um
like touch on all of the things that i'm
interested in it's got the art aspect
obviously and a bunch of like crazy
possibilities with that
um it's got the technology aspect i feel
like i'm finally
sort of using my computer science degree
here
and it's got the investing sort of
aspect of it which is something i've
also also been very sort of interested
in
um just in terms of of different market
dynamics and this and that so
to me it feels like you know the the
most interesting combination of all the
things that i'm like
super super interested in yeah and so
when you first started
uh looking at the nfts what's the first
thing that you did
uh so the first thing is a bunch of
people sort of kept
sort of uh hitting me up and being like
oh you gotta look at the sign of tea
thing you gotta look at the senate team
so the first thing i did that i remember
and this was in about mid-october
um is i i sort of looked at super rare
and it was like
what the hell like people are paying
like
huge sums of money for stuff again that
i did not think you could sell at all
and so the first thing i did was i
talked to
uh pock who is you know sort of like you
know a friend and i saw he was the top
selling
artist on super air and it was sort of
like what is going on here and so he was
nice enough to sort of
give me kind of a refresher course of or
or sort of beginner's core
you know sort of introduction into the
different platforms how the technology
works for minting
you know why people are paying this much
for it
um and sort of trying to understand like
you know just a base level what's going
on here
and from there i just doled like head
head down
just you know down the rabbit hole as
they say and really just started
reaching out to
anybody um i could who would you know
jump on a zoom call with me and sort of
like explain
uh you know where they saw this going
what the limitations were what people
have done what people have
haven't done um from the ceos of all
these platforms to collectors to artists
in the space to anybody sort of
pushing in some direction i i jumped on
a call with and like you know sort of
pick their brain
got it and so when you think about the
technology stack right now maybe walk
through people
uh how you create the digital art or you
talked a little bit about kind of the
cinema 4d uh and the rendering but then
also what the different platforms are
that you're using to actually mint this
stuff
and kind of your experience with the
various platforms in terms of either
auctions
open sales or limited editions sure so
in terms of making the art yeah like you
said
it's done in cinema 4d primarily um the
the renderer that i use is octane uh
otoy makes that and they also have a
render thing where you can sort of
render it in the cloud
um and they have a token for that as
well um
so that's the tools that is used to sort
of make the artwork along with photoshop
i usually do some sort of paint over at
the end to kind of you know
do some compositing um so from there
i i have the the everydays are
done and you know kind of ready to be
minted
in my case i sort of take those every
day's then and then have
sort of make them into videos that kind
of sort of loop through and
and show the the picture in a bit more
detail and add
a bit more information um
and then from there you know i i
honestly have only
sort of done two drops through and
they've both been through nifty gateway
so
i i've done actually three now counting
the makers but it's fun
um but so in those cases
in all those cases it's sort of it you
know it's one of these things where you
kind of
okay here's the artwork you give it to
them and they you know have sort of
handled that
um you know with places like wearable
obviously you can sort of do it yourself
but it's really one of these things
where
you upload the artwork you say the
description you pay the gas fee and
she's on the blockchain so it's not a
super huge lift
to kind of get it up there but um you
know each of the platforms obviously has
their own
uh you know sort of drawbacks and and
strengths and weaknesses the one thing i
will say
is i'm pushing all of these
[ __ ] to get [ __ ]
accept credit cards because i really
strongly feel that you know
making this as easy as possible to bring
in new users
is going to be key and the people who do
that the best are the people who are
going to have
you know the most success moving forward
absolutely
and so when you think about the
different ways you could sell your art
right there are the limited editions the
open editions and then
also uh these kind of auction based
drops are there pros and cons in your
mind to each one of those or do you
prefer one over the other
and there's absolutely pros and cons and
i think it it sort of
it it changes too over time um
so there's there's and that's another
sort of piece of this that to me is very
exciting is because you
i have all this work i have a bunch of
different work um
and i'm making it you know literally
daily making more and more of it
but the way you sort of split it up can
make a big difference for how much it
sort of sells for and it will make a big
difference
um you know long term in terms of your
career in terms of scarcity and a bunch
of different things
so that to me is something that i really
think a lot about and and things like
the dollar
edition of 100s you know trying to do
things that people have never done
before that's another piece of this that
you know is very exciting to me
looking at sort of okay what have people
done in the past okay i'm gonna try and
do something different that nobody's
ever seen
that's you know sort of structured like
that um
and so that is something that you know
really there there's no right answer it
sort of depends on
how much artwork you have how much you
want to put out at that time
but i will say that the things that i'm
very much thinking about with that is
one how can i keep some level of
scarcity
and two how can i return as much
value um back to collectors
immediately as possible
um and so that's one thing i i
you know i see people doing massive open
editions and i think that's
great you're smashing on a lot of
numbers but when you have a massive open
edition
and you know seven eight minutes
whatever
at the end of that everybody who wanted
one got one
and so there's not really that much
scarcity left over
so that that's one thing i would
definitely sort of take into account
is if everybody who got wanted one got
one
you know secondary sales and stuff like
that you you've sort of
removed some of that piece of the pie
from from sort of collectors being able
to immediately sort of
see some level of return on what they
just bought so i'm very much
trying to make it so that my work is
like
like a no-brainer like it's like okay if
i buy this thing i know it's instantly
like worth more than he's selling it for
so that's what i'm always sort of trying
to do when i when i price things and
when i
think about how many additions to put
out got it and so when you think through
this
why is the nft market taking off so much
is this just the bubble
is it unsustainable but like what's your
analysis as to why there's so much
interest and so much demand right now
in this market specifically i think
there's a couple things
i think there is definitely a lot of
fight i think there's no way to not be
like
okay there's people are people are going
ape [ __ ]
um so i i'm not you know
so naive to think that that's not a
piece of it
um yet at the same time and so i think
there's this thing where it's kind of
it may be a bubble but it's sort of one
of these
things where i also see a huge amount of
legitimate
long-term value for this this is an
asset class
and i think we've only scratched the
surface of
um different mechanics for how these can
work
um different utility use cases because a
lot of the utility use cases you know
could be dependent on things that happen
in the real world and right now the real
world's kind of
you know everything's got a big asterisk
around it because of koben so
we really haven't even been able to see
a lot of these utility use cases really
sort of
um you know played out um i look at
people who are
sort of like oh you know this you know
if you buy this nft it gets you some
backstage
you know concert well those concerts
aren't able to like happen yet so
we haven't really even seen that kind of
play out um but i think
there are just so many uses for this
stuff and i think it's such an
interesting new um you know
way to to sort of store value that i
think
you know people are seeing that and i
think sort of long term
like macro high level looking at this as
an asset class
i think this could be something that
really
sort of appeals to um you know
younger sort of uh investors and i think
there's nothing really
written in stone that investors you know
right now the
the for the last 50 so years or whatever
the predominant way that people sort of
invested was like equities
and there's nothing that says that has
to just keep going forever
and i think a lot of younger investors
they kind of hate
corporations they really don't like
companies and so
to think that they're automatically just
going to
invest their money in companies moving
forward like i don't know that i would
that's not set in stone like they could
look at other things that speak more to
them
in terms of asset classes and i think
nfts could be a huge huge
um you know piece of that moving forward
that they would rather invest in in
something that
you know they have a bit more ownership
over um
and they can sort of do what they want
with a little more and they identify
with more
than sort of okay i grew up let me put
my money in ge
and ibm and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] that i
don't give a [ __ ] about or like
this doesn't speak to me and i it um you
know
is it really something i want to support
in some ways so
i think that well there is a lot of hype
right now
i think um it also feels like we're
still very much at the beginning of this
so when you think through kind of what's
working what's not working are there
specific
things uh whether it's in kind of your
formula for success
or other things you see in the market
where you're like this is definitely
kind of a winning strategy
uh from the artist perspective um
that's a good question um
i really think there's a lot of
different like things and
obviously like you know it's not just me
who's seeing a tremendous amount of sort
of
you know growth and success in this
space so i think there's a lot of things
that that people are trying that are
are you know working quite well um
and i i don't think there's one sort of
like this is the path
and i think um you know
it's evolving very quickly too i i look
at like the hash mass thing
and like that you know had like a
massive you know sort of moment and then
i think you're gonna see a bunch of
generative
um sort of projects happen from that
um i i think there's just a bunch of
different mechanics that people have not
tried yet
to with the smart contracts and making
these sort of gamifying the ownership
experience a bit more of the collecting
experience so i think that's something
that you know there's still a huge
amount of potential there
um but yeah i think that that to me is
it's sort of the fun part of this is it
feels like we're at the beginning and
we're writing the rules and so i don't
think there's necessarily
one like this is what you should do
release this kind of this
and also because each artist is
different like i have
5 000 you know pieces that i spent two
or three hours on
and some people have like oh here's you
know i've got five pieces of work that
i've done but i spent two years on each
one of them you know
how do i sort of split that up so i
think there's there's really a bunch of
different you know
paths to success with this stuff what
did you sell your first piece
for as an nst you remember so the the
first drop that i had was
in october um and i had sort of three
pieces
two videos um and um
then the addition of 100 for a dollar
and so
the two videos one of them sort of uh
changed based on the election it had
sort of an initial state and then it it
was going to change and this was again
about five days before the election um
so if biden won it was going to change
the one video and if trump won it was
going to change for a different video so
it obviously ended up changing to the
the biting video and that's kind of how
it will stay from now on
um so that piece those both of those
pieces then i did
another piece um you know with that for
auction and both of those pieces went
for 66 thousand
dollars to pablo uh you sold them for 66
000 but you also did a drop of
one dollar for the other
pieces yep so those were one dollar and
it was an addition of 100 and so
obviously those sold
instantly and then people can sort of
flip those immediately
right through sort of nifty this was
done on nifty gateway and so people can
immediately flip those
and so i my thinking with that was okay
i know they're worth more than a dollar
but i i figured maybe they'd be worth
like a hundred dollars
and so immediately within 45 minutes
somebody had flipped the
flip one for about a thousand dollars
and it was like oh my god
like somebody sold that for a thousand
dollars that's crazy
and then by the end of the night
somebody had sold one for six thousand
dollars and it was like
what the hell like that is you know was
just absolutely insane to me
fast forward now you can't get one of
those for less than 150
000 one went for 300 000
like it is like insane again those were
a dollar
in october so um when you think through
going from selling one dollar pieces to
one of your pieces just sold for six
point six million dollars
yes one of those sixty six thousand yeah
yeah trump in all his glory with no
clothes on laying in the uh
yeah i'm gonna get straight up [ __ ]
murdered by one of these q anon morons
what happened why did it go for so much
who bought it why
like what is going on with the 6.6
million dollar
nft well i think like it's one of these
things where the whole space is like you
know
going crazy like this is not sort of
happening in a vacuum and i think people
are are sort of seeing again obviously
the
christie's sale was a huge impact of
that and people are sort of
um you know seeing that that this could
be
a massive massive um you know kind of
thing and me being one of the like you
know most popular artists in the space i
think they're
sort of attaching premiums to that but
there's also been
different things that have kind of shown
the price
sort of there's been different sort of
metrics i think the 6.6
if you're looking at an addition of 100
and those are going for
150 000 each then you can take the fully
diluted value of those 100 and it's like
okay well that's like you know
10 million dollars for that piece of
artwork or whatever
15 million dollars and so looking at the
in the context of that
you're like oh okay i guess 6.6 is not
just out of nowhere
um and then if you factor in like the
b20 token which is this whole
other like you know i don't know if you
want to get into that but that's a whole
other sort of thing that
also right now is about 100 million
dollars
divided by 20 pieces there you kind of
you know are coming to a similar number
explain what that is for everyone so the
b20
is uh kind of a a long story you kind of
need to know about
about d5 to some degree but i'll try and
sum it up you know kind of quickly here
but
so basically what it is is um in my
second drop
i did like a 20 20 collection and part
of that drop i did
20 individual one of one um
pieces and so what happened is um
somebody bought all 20 of those pieces
kind of sort of secretly throughout the
weekend and kind of you know sort of
tricked everybody
and ended up getting all of those pieces
and uh he did that for a very specific
reason because he then took those 20
pieces
and built virtual museums for them
insomnium space in the central land and
a few other places built virtual museums
bought land
they had museums built specifically for
those 20 pieces
then he took and bundled that all
together into a smart contract
locked it into a smart contract and
fractionalized that
into 10 million shares so the amount
with the the pieces that he bought
which was about 2.2 million dollars and
the land
all said and done he spent about 3.5
million dollars
and as of right now that
b20 and then he split it into 10 million
um
10 million uh uh
you know sort of fractions and made a
token out of it
and so right now that token is valued at
91 million dollars if you take the like
thing and this was one month
that he did this ago he did this june
january 23rd and so it's been on sale a
little over a month
five weeks or so and is now worth 91
million dollars from that initial 3.5
million dollars
so um
yeah it's very like
it's great it's securitization it's
virtual worlds
it's digital art it's all this wrapped
up is what is why some people are so
excited about this
uh but then you you weren't satisfied
right you're literally
the best as artist in the world and then
you said i'm gonna go take on the man
i'm gonna go
uh get in bed with the incumbent and you
went and did this christy's auction
what did you do why did you do it and
how did it work
sure so the the christie's auction came
through maker's place actually they were
the ones who sort of like brokered that
deal and sort of like organized that and
they reached out to me and we're sort of
like you know we
we want kind of uh sort of the leading
person in this space to kind of you know
represent this and be the first
and so i was super honored um and i look
at it as
as sort of uh recognition and
the reason i wanted to do it um is
because
i think obviously this this there's some
validation from
you know selling something on nifty
gateway but i think there's a different
level of validation from selling
something
you know a digital piece of our work um
that has no physical component
um through a 255 year old auction house
um that is selling you know
rembrandts and you know war halls and
you know two years ago they sold a you
know leonardo da vinci painting and just
crazy [ __ ] like very much
obviously a historical uh you know
something that is
is very much part of of art history over
you know centuries um and so
i think that brings a different level of
validation and something that
um i think will will really help boost
the entire space and to be quite honest
i think it already has
helped boost the entire space just since
that's been announced
you've seen a fairly market uptick in in
like you know
other nifty gateway sales and and you
know across the board sort of interested
in this stuff
so what is the auction like how does it
exactly work
yeah so the auction is it started on
um thursday of last week and it goes
until march 11th
uh 11th or 12th i think 11. um
and so it's like a 17-day auction or
whatever it's on christy's
you know website you need to be sort of
vetted by them
um and so the the piece that i'm sort of
auctioning
is kind of all 5 000 of the first
uh every day's the first 5 000 days of
every day in sort of
one giant mosaic image um if you look at
the very upper left-hand corner you see
the very first everyday
and the bottom right hand corner you see
the 5 000th every day which was just
last month um and so it's one jpeg
one massive massive jpeg that
encompasses
all of those images so i mean it's
something you could literally look at
for
hours upon hours upon hours and never
like really sort of
be able to kind of see everything guess
what it goes for what do you think the
winning bid is not guessing bro
not guessing a lot of people are trying
to give me the gas i'm not guessing what
do you think
what is it at right now we got three
right now three million
yep 50.
okay so here's a little contact if it
goes for more than
20 it will be in the top 10
highest uh um
sort of highest uh grossing or whatever
highest sold artworks by a living artist
ever if it goes for 20 it will be in the
top 10
ever like most expensive artworks by a
living artist so
we're getting into some wacom 50
[ __ ]
we're getting into some wacky numbers
here um
so it is very
yeah listen why can't it go for 50.
like i'm not stopping it i'm not going
to stop it from going for 50.
it's just like hearing that and and to
be quite honest you're not the first
producer says that i was doing it like
right before it opened i was doing a
clubhouse
with um cz from buying finance
and he kept being a hundred million
hundred million like right at the end of
the like clubhouse he's like okay great
it's gonna go over a hundred million bye
it's just jesus christ no cz he's rich
he could buy 400
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is going on but at the
same time like i look at it and it's
like that
sounds crazy but it's like i don't know
i also see like just
so much potential and i just feel like
this could be
a really like just not not just art like
this
really truly could be even if if nft
captured a tiny fraction
just like with bitcoin even if they
captured a tiny fraction of the
traditional sort of like
equity market you're talking about
literally a hundred if not a thousand
times from where we are now in terms of
total market cap
i mean the total market cap of nfts is
maybe
250 million or something like that like
it is that is a drop in the bucket of
what it could be
talk to me about uh the physical tokens
um
before we talk about kind of the
investment case the physical tokens
uh that you created this is i think
you're the first and only person to have
done this so far
uh for those that are just listening and
not watching uh mike just got up and
walked away now
he's back now okay i'm back now all
right
this physical token is yeah so these are
the the
you know sort of physical tokens that
were sold with the last drop and this is
something that i think is is to me
really interesting and something that
i'm excited to sort of explore more
because i think this is something that
for a lot of people can be a great
sort of entryway into this stuff because
it's one of these things where it's like
what the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] would i buy a
jpeg what the [ __ ] is this stuff it's
like okay
you don't really need you don't even
let's just take all those arguments off
the table what am i buying you're buying
this thing
okay that's it i get it like it's one of
these for those people who are just
listening
basically it is uh maybe a one
foot by one foot uh give or take uh
almost looks like plexiglas but inside
of the place
yeah it's sort of like it's like a it's
kind of like uh looks like
sort of a um like a kindle fire
type thing you know encased in acrylic
um
and so it's it really just keeps looping
through the the video it's a video
screen
and it sort of keeps looping through it
and it's something that you can just put
on your
put on your bookshelf and and i'll plug
it in and it just keeps playing there's
no interface there's no buttons there's
no turning it off changing the video
um it's got a signed uh this one's not
signed or whatever but it's got a signed
number
titanium backplate so that it shows you
know your edition
um and then it's also the video itself
has a qr code
and what that qr code does is if you
scan that it goes to peoplecollect.com
that has you know additional information
about this artwork
and immediately shows who owns the
artwork
um and immediately shows how the the
artwork was made and it's just something
to sort of like
uh a community to kind of tie the the
sort of you know collectors together
people who like own this stuff and so
you know i i wanted to do something
because the people have
done sort of physical um you know sort
of things in the
past tying nfts with these but it always
seemed
very you know sort of separate like okay
you get a print with it
well which is worth more the print or
you know then ft
and i wanted it to be something where
they were very sort of tied together and
they felt like one
cohesive um very digital product
um that that you wouldn't really sort of
think of separating
so along with that we we did wanted to
do some really like cool packaging and
something that would really sort of
you know get people excited about
you know getting this stuff and so we
did these um
you know boxes that that really tried to
put like a bunch of sort of like time
and energy into
making something that would be really
fun and like exciting for people to
to unbox so what's in the boxes what's
up
what are the things in uh in the box so
the box has
you know obviously it has the frame then
it has another certificate that sort of
you know has the token id and
has some some extra sort of like details
there it's got a cleaning cloth and then
it also has
a hair sample what is the hair stamping
pubes a lot of people are saying it's
cubes it specifically says there it's
not
cubes so i'm just gonna why is there
why didn't you put a hair sample in the
everyday box
um so the reason is
my has gotten up and left again hold on
my name my name um
beeple actually comes from
this toy from the 80s that you sort of
cover its eyes
is it not doing it now you cover its
eyes and it beeps okay now it doesn't
want to be but it's
it um this is actually a beeple like
this is what i'm named after this is
what i named
myself as a designer after you know 20
years ago or whatever
and so that's this is what the hair is
from it's not goddamn cubes you freaking
perverts
so this is it's hair shaved off of this
like you know for people
listening to this like it's like an ewok
looking uh
little sort of toy um that you can get
off of ebay for like 20 bucks they're
not really bad like
you know i love it or whatever but
that's that's a people and so that's
what the hair is
all right so when you think about all of
this
uh you started out you know whatever 20
years ago
uh trying to figure out how to be an
artist how to use a lot of these
technologies
and you've now kind of grinded your way
to the number one digital artist in the
world
uh what's changed like did you go and
buy a private jet
did you uh order a bunch of dominoes uh
you know what what's changed about your
life um
honestly nothing because it's sort of
like i really
still like see a huge amount of room for
improvement
you know each day um
i think the pictures could be much
better and
um you know i think there's
uh a bunch of different areas
in that that i think that could be
better from color composition
form i mean really i think there's quite
a lot of room
for improvement so that that's something
that really sort of keeps me going
and now i i think bringing in the the
physical aspect that is something that
i'm super super excited about to
start exploring and something that you
know as a digital artist i never really
thought of it and i think it's ironic
that as a digital
artist this nft technology pushed me
into making physical art and i think
it's really going to do
the opposite for the other side i think
it's going to take
physical artists and they're going to
look at this and be like okay how can i
make my work more digital
and so i think you're really going to
see this massive explosion of creativity
from both sides
sort of pushing you know the the
technology in different ways and i'm you
know
super super excited to sort of be a part
of that
and i think it's also going to be um
you know oh i think this technology is
going to open up a new chapter in art
history and sort of
uh i think there there's going to be
people sort of going back and looking at
this digital art that's been made over
the last 20 years and sort of really
recognizing that as a true art form and
something that you can now collect
absolutely uh when you think of this as
an investment class kind of like an
alternative asset i know you got a bunch
of thoughts there
is this something that's sustainable
will you know institutional investors
eventually have a digital art allocation
how does that work
i think it would i absolutely think it
will be i think
um again i think it's it's one of these
things where
i think collectibles in in general um
and art in general art does pretty well
like blue chip if you look at the like
higher end
you know art year-over-year returns on
stuff it does quite well versus
versus other asset classes so i think
it's something where
um right now there's a lot of
speculation it is very
speculative and i think one thing that
that people do need to be careful of on
this
is to be quite honest a lot of these
nfts will go to zero
like that's just if you look at like uh
traditionally art
the very top appreciates quite well
and the the bottom 90 like they
do not do well and they will will
probably lose money so it is something
that you know
just because somebody made an nft out of
something doesn't mean it automatically
has value
like that's that's definitely not the
case anybody can sort of make an nft out
of anything that there's no promise just
because
oh it's an nft like it just magically
has any value
um so it's definitely something where i
would look at people who have you know
sort of been around a while and
sort of uh you know that it's not just
getting caught in
the hype of you know the shiny new thing
um so i think it's it's something that
you know looking at like that the the
b20 thing it's sort of like this guy
bought these nfts and then he was able
to sort of use them to do this other
thing to actually make more money
so you really have a high degree of
ownership over these things versus if
you have a stock
it's sort of like well you know you
that's it
like you kind of you don't have a bunch
of like you know things you can kind of
do
on top of that to do do what you want
with it and and
as we're seeing with like the gamestop
thing is even the rules that you
thought you had about owning that stock
can change on a dime
and so that's another thing that i think
people are going to look at with this as
an asset class and be like
maybe that you know could be something
that could be a you know
an actual store of value in some
respects
what do you think about your portfolio
is it all crypto is it all
digital art is it in traditional like a
bunch of people are asking online just
in terms of how you think about
investing and allocating your own
uh portfolio so i'm honestly quite new
to crypto and like
again like i before this i had bought
a little bit of aetherium in 2017
just like everybody and their freaking
grandma did and saw it go up
saw it go down never really thought
about it just you know
just a small amount to kind of you know
jump in the game a little bit here
um since i've come to this space
i definitely started allocating much
more of my and i
understand crypto now and i understand
the value proposition of both bitcoin
and ethereum much better now uh now i've
allocated
a much bigger proportion so now it's
it's about 33
of my my portfolio is you know currently
portfolio
is sort of allocated to like crypto the
rest is mostly in
um traditional sort of like stocks and
like to be quite honest i'm not that
uh you know sort of aggressive as a
ambassador and very much sort of like
set it and forget it and sort of you
know something that will just
grow incrementally over time um and so
most of that
stuff is regular equities and mostly
like tech stocks and some
uh etfs and stuff do you buy um
art from other artists or do you
basically say look my exposure to
artists through my own work
and um and then you just kind of cheer
them on from the sideline
i have not bought any other art to be
honest i actually don't think i
bought a single nft and i think it's one
of these things where i just don't have
this like collab i've been so
busy like sort of uh you know
building my own stuff that it is i
haven't had like a chance to sort of
like
dive in from like a collecting aspect to
to
sort of you know start start investing
in this stuff
um so it's one of those things where
i also kind of feel like i don't know
like i feel like there's so many i have
so many friends creating stuff like i
i feel like once i open that i'm a
little hesitant to open that can of
worms it's like well why didn't you buy
my thing
why didn't you buy my thing because i
have a million friends creating digital
art that it's sort of like
i can't i can literally you know
wouldn't be able to sort of
buy all the amazing stuff out there so
it's definitely you know i think it's
it's it's
super cool but it's something i i still
need to process how i'm gonna sort of
like me personally you know i'm gonna
approach that
all right i've got five questions for
you we're going to run through
these before lightning round
what is that what do you consider your
biggest personal achievement
uh the chrissy's thing ah all right
that's great
it's ongoing it's live let's roll okay i
don't know we were quick
second uh question is what is the one
artist that you would most like to
collaborate with uh
aphex twin that's a great suggestion
third question what is the most
important book that you've ever written
um the war of art
by stephen field um that
is a book that i would say probably
i never read books i almost never in the
last 20 years i've maybe read two to
three books
um so i just don't read books i like
reading the news
i like reading i should not like reading
books um
that book it was very sort of like
inspirational and something that i think
was
i read it right when i started the
everydays around there so i think that
was a big
big sort of part of that all right next
question comes from our friends over at
eight sleep
uh i gotta imagine you're like me uh
last year
i've slept very very little before the
pandemic hit like five six hours was
horrible
i got myself an eight sleeve which is
this like thermo-regulated bed
i turn it real cold sleep on it like a
baby now i get
eight nine hours like a new man what's
your sleep schedule and how has it
changed
um yeah it honestly is
not it's very a bit all over the place
because i'll wake up after like
three hours and it's like i've got a
million ideas nfps
what the [ __ ] like what's going on like
it's it's
such a freaking crazy rabbit hole that
i maybe i need to get one of those
whatever that pelvic called
hate sleep eight sleep mattress
better art with eight sleep that's what
that's what i'm gonna start telling
people
i'm gonna say people makes better art
when he sleeps on an ate
sleep
[Laughter]
uh all right last question very
important question then you get to ask
me one to finish this up
alien are you a believer or a
non-believer
in aliens yes um
probably there's probably some sort i
mean i don't think there's
aliens that we've seen but i think
there's probably aliens out there i
don't know
like i would say yes ish
yes it is what is your quest what do you
think
i think there's aliens but they're too
far away so we're never going to
actually come in contact with them
during your my life so it doesn't really
matter
that's probably what i would say as well
that is probably what i would say
like existence and communication are two
really big different things
yeah you could be on the other side of
the universe and it's kind of like cool
yeah don't come over here we won't come
over there and we'll all be good
we're pretty far away we could be pretty
far away from the next person
all right you could ask me one question
what do you got for me um
what technology in the crypto space are
you most excited about
i'm going to bid 50 million dollars on
this beeple piece at christie's
okay good answer good [ __ ]
answer okay
i like it that's a wrap we're out
no you heard him you heard him he's
[ __ ] committed 50 million dollars you
owe me 50 million dollars
going to bid 51 million so the bag's his
uh what what uh where can we send people
to find you on social media find the
everydays online
and find more of the work you're doing
uh with the nfts um i think if you just
google people you'll find you know
instagram and all the other
goodness there so there's no shortage of
places to uh
you know you've arrived when you just
tell people google me
yeah except i still don't have a goddamn
wikipedia [ __ ] page
if anybody can uh get me a wikipedia
page watching this
there there's your homework assignment
get people a wikipedia page all right
people want a wikipedia page that means
if you downloaded the podcast or the
video you listen
all the way to the end and you have the
ability to create a wikipedia page
if you hook people up with it and tweet
at us he'll probably
do nothing other than say thank you uh
he'll do a lot more and say thank you
but yes awesome man listen thank you so
much for doing this you're absolutely
killing it it's so fun to watch
i appreciate that and we'll talk soon
awesome